[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined by
my co-host dr greg sadler and today
we're talking about
empathy as human in philip k dick's
works and so this might be a little bit
of a departure this is the first time
that we are
devoting an entire episode to talking
about
a work of speculative fiction and a
great author
in that genre i mean we've talked about
it before
and
um
we just never devoted an entire episode
to it so
dan and i were chatting and we were like
yeah we were both
big fans of philip k dick and there will
be plenty of jokes in this because the
fans of philip k dick are known as
[ __ ] and so you know we get to make
all sorts of dick jokes uh off of his
name we'll probably try to keep that to
some sort of minimum but we're both huge
fans some showed like level yeah exactly
so you know there were some some things
that we wanted to hit on and
i kind of thought well
let's look at
probably his most famous
work
famous in part because of its film
adaptation into the
the blade runner and there's there's so
much going on in the android's dream of
electric sheep which is the novel
that the blade runner was uh
drawn from so
we're probably going to be all over the
map i think in this one
um
just such a plethora of different uh
topics and you know
rabbit trails to go down for us that's
right so we're gonna have to resist
going down into rabbit holes and never
coming out or going further and further
into like a labyrinth of rabbit holes
um so look like a maze of death oh
there's another one of dick's uh books
that i think has not been adapted into a
film right
i uh as far as i know no and i think
i've i've tracked down every single film
adaptation even some of the really
really bad ones like screamers
yeah i remember seeing that and and then
reading uh the short story afterwards
and being like oh that was not a good
one
but we're gonna the but the short story
is so good oh man that that um
the
twist at the end is i guess you could
kind of see it coming but it's a really
good twist he's good at doing that this
is a little bit off topic but yeah dick
dick rivals oh henry who was the master
of the twist in literature
um he probably in at least in his short
stories i i don't know if we can say
that about his novels so much
they don't usually end with like a
little zinger or something
yeah but like a lot of the short stories
yes definitely
like
it's it's hard like i love his novels
but there's something that's
about like maybe it's just the editing
process and short stories that really
keep the the idea in a really short like
okay you know it's like making a tv show
um that's you know has to be 22 minutes
okay you're cutting all the craft right
right
yeah one of the one of my favorite short
stories and i forget the name of it
there's a guy who's kind of a jerk to
his wife
and he goes off on some mission to
another planet and another star system
and he comes back and she notices we'll
remember it for you wholesale i don't
think it's that one um no he comes back
and he is different
he's attentive he's loving
he
looks at their kid as if he's like a
real father
and her now that i remember her brother
is like one of these guys who's in
charge of like making sure aliens are
not infiltrating our society
and she realizes that he's been replaced
by an alien
but she covers it up
because
she likes this guy better
so the lesson out there for for you you
know uh hearing this is you better be on
your guard to be a decent person because
otherwise you might be replaced by
somebody who and well this is a good
segue somebody who has more empathy
right
right
um so
we're
if we want we can go a little bit into
kind of the overarching themes that
we're going to be talking about here
with yeah let's do that
so um we're talking mostly here about do
android stream of electric sheep which
is the uh
uh what became known as blade runner
when ridley scott made it into a film
starring harrison ford in the 1980s yeah
um 82 i think 82 and um so we've got a
number of different things here
specifically
um
ideas in
empathy what like makes a human a human
um and also a lot about um memory and
how
um these things affect both our our
humanity or just even like um what makes
someone to have a value
ins there
and then
what makes a person a person right
yeah yeah how do you make that
distinction especially if we're talking
about which one of the major uh
ideas discussed here is you know on
these artificial humans the nexus models
uh the next six models specifically um
here are these from the i guess in the
movie it's the tyrell corporation and i
forget what the the version rose
incorporation yeah i'd forgotten that it
was a different corporation there's so
many we're going to get to this in a bit
but there's so many divergences between
the movie and the book a lot of which
seem to be kind of unnecessary so
instead of it being androids it's
replicants instead of it being um
bounty hunters it's blade runners you
know
so um as well as like you know whole
big areas like mercerism that is
absolutely cut out uh you know rick
deckard actually has a wife in the book
where he's not but like well let's get
to the themes first we'll be digging in
let's let's talk about dick um
because you can never get enough talking
about dick right oh yeah i love dick
so who who was this guy for i think a
lot of people know him by reputation but
maybe they don't know that much about
him we're not going to like do a whole
biography here we just want some context
for people who might not be as familiar
with his his work and his thought and
his life and his influence so the first
thing you can say about the guy is he's
a science fiction writer and he
was in the solidly in the the 20th
century he dies in 1982 shortly before
blade runner comes out
but he he was very prolific he wrote you
know dozens of novels short stories
lived most of his life in california
that's where a lot of the
stories are actually set
and
i will point out that he wrote what are
called realistic novels as well but the
poor guy got pigeonholed as a sci-fi
writer so these realistic novels like um
milton lumke territory they nobody would
publish them
and they've been subsequently published
as a matter of fact he had kind of a
hard life
uh philip k dick
um
very colorful
um
kind of tragic
married five times
a lot of strange relationships uh did a
lot of drugs over the course of his life
which doesn't really help things out as
a matter of fact he uh he had a
connection with ursula k le guin they
actually went to high school together
but didn't know each other at the time
and they did like get connected later
and she was like i don't want you
visiting my house because i don't want
to i don't want my kids seeing all this
drug use and you're kind of erratic so
so there's that side um i did just
interject um yeah one of the things that
really that brought it home is that the
the epilogue or like the the afterward
for um
scanner scanner yeah yeah talks about
one his experience
and how it has
made his life worse as well as it runs
through a
uh a list of the people that he's been
close to who have either died or have
been
severely crippled due to their drug use
and so it's really sobering
especially because the major themes of
that book are all about drug use to the
point of
becoming
unmoored from reality
yeah you know another theme that fits in
there that connects up with
the android's dream of electric sheep he
talks about the drug user um for this
this drug and i forget the name of it
um
becoming almost like an insect a mere
stimulus response machine which is what
we're seeing
the um
androids being reduced to as well
the question is
are they yeah yeah
so you know he there's there's a huge
book that i actually have a copy of it
so it's so big it's probably about like
four pounds the exegesis of philip k
dick
and you know you can read your way
through it and find out what was going
on in his head i don't i don't find it
particularly helpful for the android
stream of electric sheep necessarily but
um
it's it's interesting that he spent so
much time on that project trying to make
sense out of this spiritual experience
that he had and clearly the things that
he was writing were not just to make
money which he didn't do an awful lot of
and or to get fame which again didn't
get a lot of in his lifetime
unfortunately
um he was
he was like kind of doing philosophical
work
through his literature
absolutely i mean i think that's like
the reason why both of us are kind of
enthralled by his writings and the
reason that we are even bringing this up
here and so like there's lots of sci-fi
writers that out there that i think we
both enjoy but it's not something that
like oh yeah i definitely have to you
know dig into the philosophical ideas
that are in a lot of these books because
they're usually pretty you know briefed
of of something significantly diff deep
as well as something that is um
novel and it feels like dick really you
know explored areas that were
novel to the world experience at least
written
yeah if he wasn't the person who came up
with it he found a new
take a new spin to put on it
um this is kind of a good way time to
jump into like what it is that we
particularly like about dick
and we can talk you know if we have time
later about the different film
adaptations we'll just point out that
unfortunately dick did not live
to see
um the first film adaptation blade
runner in the theaters he got to see a
director's cut before he
died of complications of a stroke in
1982
so
you mentioned one thing that you
particularly like about
dick's works what else is it that you
like about him
um like
the there's a recurring
uh theme of
dealing with reality and how we interact
with it um and either you know what
we're talking about like through
spiritual means through through drug
means through you know potentially being
dead in a another universe or on you
know what it is to be you know uh a
android and that um reality and that
being in the universe in how we interact
as those characters or not
he's constantly
trying to
investigate different ways in which our
uh either our perceptions or the actual
ontology of the world that we're living
in is changing a lot of times this is in
commune with others and something that
will
show up here and do android stream of
electric sheep um but also in commune
with like some other um
large creature that you become like
immersed in in a like a communal
consciousness um and that is
uh
something definitely that uh people have
says born out from partly his his drug
use and then having a different um
change in perception from that and uh
and leading him to a point where um he
might not know exactly where his own
reality ends and a false reality ends
and he's trying to uh investigate that
through his novels and works yeah i i
really like how the characters are
in effect doing philosophy and playing
around with ideas from philosophy or
psychology
or in some cases theology
they they get woven into
um their thoughts their interactions the
as we nowadays call them info dumps
where a character is explaining
something to another character
and every time that dick does it you
you know first of all he actually has
read the stuff he's done the work
but he's not going to present it like an
academic does he's going to like put it
into a framework that we can relate to
and we're like oh yeah that idea
actually has some practical effects at
least in this imaginary universe
and i i love that about his his works
yeah um and we'll get to it later but
like one of the the people that
uh i guess kind of a similar idea is
he's um
the the mood organ which is all right
tool in which
the
the characters are using in order to
like experience things kind of on to to
make uh feelings of either depression or
mania or anything in between there um
but it's um
uh penfield is a pen-filled yeah um
yeah and penfield is actually a real
person he is a um
was a surgeon who was one of the first
people to he's a brain surgeon
specifically person
came out and while he was doing brain
surgery he was started on the first
person to uh intellectually stimulate
portions of the brain and ask them while
they're still conscious what are they
thinking yeah and so not only are they
having those memories come to mind but
uh if you hit the right places people
would actually experience their memories
as if they were physically embodied in
them and so this is
an interesting idea from actual science
that he is now brought in as a an object
in which the characters are using on a
day-to-day basis i think the mood organ
and this is something that is left out
of the blade runner is a really
interesting idea just by itself the
notion that we can tinker around
with how we're feeling or even what we
desire because there's a there's a mood
organ
setting
uh the that creates the desire to dial
another mood right so it's kind of
self-referential so if you if it's sort
of like people who can't decide what
they should eat for dinner right
you're at a certain point you're like
just just pick something so there's
there's a button for that
this notion that we're not we're not
totally
um passive
we have an agency in it and yet we get
to like literally push our own buttons
it's really an interesting
uh conjecture isn't it i mean we kind of
do stuff like this with what like
foucault calls technologies of the self
or
um pure dough calls uh spiritual
exercises where we're taking things from
maybe ancient philosophy like stoicism
or epicureanism and we're you know like
doing negative visualization that's a
way of pushing our own buttons right
um but this is a mechanical means for it
and there's like a catalog in the book
that um
and uh uh rick deckard's wife is paging
through to figure out what she wants to
dial up next
um as well as i believe like this is the
very first one of the very first scenes
in the book if not the very first yeah
yeah is there they're talking about this
and it ends kind of on this cheeky
moment and when he's like oh you know
dial up the um my husband always knows
what's right
later on later on in the book she's
depressed again when he calls and he's
like what happened to mood and i forget
it's like 613. she's like oh yeah as
soon as you left i dialed a different
mood
yeah and as you were talking about like
um there's uh she in the
dialed it to be depressive twice a month
i think um yeah and then but how's uh
three hours for her to be in this
depressive mood in which then it will
automatically switch to another thing in
the future to make sure that because if
you're
constantly in this suppressed mood then
you'll maybe not ever ever will have the
desire
exactly
yeah and we should we should talk about
that a little bit
you know one of the the reasons
why in the the book she says that she
should do that like almost like purging
herself
um
every so often is because they're living
in
an environment in which um
human beings have become much more
scarce and so there's all these empty
apartments and she
she is not being bothered by it yeah
yeah well that's right everybody's
emigrating to the the colonies or to
mars and that's that's there in the the
movie but it's never really explained
what the effect of that is isidore lives
in a place all by himself and there's
just you know
every other apartment is filled with
garbage basically they call kipple you
know the breakdown of of things and it's
very you get the sense that there's like
a deep loneliness
that
erin thinks we should um feel bad about
an experience every once in a while we
shouldn't this goes to the reality thing
right do we live in a
reality that we manufacture for
ourselves where we feel okay and happy
or do we allow ourselves to feel the
negative moods that
are
reflecting the reality that we're in you
know so a little background you just
grabbed talked about isidore so this is
jr is another character that doesn't
actually appear in the movie no no he
does but he's changed
they've changed him so much i don't
consider the same character well that's
interesting
um because he's at least within
the book he is
uh what they call a chicken head he's
been
hit by the radiation so you know another
step back here yeah they're living the
reason why everyone's immigrating on
earth is that there was a a world war
terminus in which it was a nuclear war
so we've
ruined
the environment to the point where large
portions of the earth are uh
uninhabitable and have lots of radiation
yeah this has caused mutations or
degradations in the populace and if you
uh the degradation happens in your brain
then you become what they refer to as a
chicken head
this is what yeah yeah special um and
and if you're special you can't
uh emigrate off the planet anymore and
so jr is a door at least in the book is
a special mentally um
and
um in that he's been uh he removes
himself from society in part because of
how society has been treating him as
this special
yeah and he um he has to have a pretty
menial job as well you know what we
should do is we should jump ahead we'll
come back to like some of the passages
that we've got selected from this great
speech that dick gave the android and
the human but let's actually like
overview the
the book and the movie a bit so anybody
who doesn't already have these you know
ready to mind knows precisely what we're
talking about so as dan said there's
there's a world war and that happens a
long time ago it creates this
radioactive dust um which is a big
problem men have to go around in lead
cod pieces to you know protect their
their precious junk and um there's
there's a lot of things going wrong with
this this world
protect their philip k dicks
[Laughter]
and they're they're accompanying uh i
mean the real payoff is is protecting
the
the nuts right and uh speaking of nuts
there are very few squirrels left in
this world just as there's very few
animals um and so animals have become
rare
and human beings have
um you know if we think about empathy
today right there's lots of people who
are abusive to animals we can say well
that's not a distinctively
human trait in our present but in in
this future
human beings feel empathy towards
animals they want to protect them they
want to
you know comfort them they want to take
care of them and that's that's a sign
of
humanity
and go ahead
this is specifically spurred on by this
religious movement right called
mercerism yeah and so in the advent of a
a
global nuclear war
on a
religious individual named mercer
has risen up and
um in the you know in the wake of this
massive devastation um
preaches this thing of
uh empathy as as the core theme and so
you show your empathy not only for like
others humans but specifically in taking
care and so one of the main tenets of
the religion is to take care of some
other living creature some animal
and because they're so
uh uncommon because of you know nuclear
war
people will buy electric versions of
these animals thus the name of the book
do android stream of electric sheep
people have electric sheep rick deckard
has an electric sheep in which he takes
care of and so not only is um and then
the other major tenant of this religion
is also to use this mood organ that we
were talking about earlier in order to
share these empathetic feelings with
everyone else there it's the empathy box
though
so you you oh yeah they're very handles
and
and yeah you you share fusion is what
they call it um
and it's not just mood you like
i mean what is this is this a
hallucination is this participating in
mercer's memories
i mean it can i think i think it's it's
both well because another tenet of the
religion is put forward is to um
physically feel uh so
uh mercer has this either like
sisyphusian and or kind of christ-like
thing where he walks up this hill and
he's pelted by stones and at the top of
the hill he dies yeah this idea is to
like uh with this empathy box you grab
both things and you are physically
feeling um not only just like the the
straight like visual and perceptual
feelings but you're feeling being pelted
with stones and that's to to
create a greater um empathetic
connection with um this
individual as well as everyone else
around you and it seems to work you know
quite well um
so unfortunately it's a good fraud
well
yes and no i mean uh it's interesting in
the book so
there's this big revelation
that um
happens uh
short maybe like three quarters of the
way through the book
where
that dan's referring to where mercer was
actually an actor and it was filmed and
you can see the set things behind him
and this buster friendly reveals it on
the air um buster friendly's been around
for decades he's uh like a
tv host yeah and he might be an android
himself for all we know um but the the
main going back to kind of like an
overview of the story the main conflict
in here is that rick deckard is a bounty
hunter in the book otherwise known as a
blade runner in the movie in which his
job is to um hunt down and find these
replicants who have returned to earth
after being um you know
slave labor basically and and
throwing over their masters out in the
colonies to come
and hide out on earth yeah and so it's
illegal for them to be present on earth
and they're all like the top of the line
they're nexus sixes who have the best
brains and and and you know the best
reflexes yeah
and so um
going back to the mercer is something
mercerism says it's okay to kill the
killers
and right and the androids are the
killers in part because
they um they do kill human beings but
they also lack empathy for animals and
for each other they don't they don't uh
they don't have that response that human
beings do
or at least they are purported to yeah
have lack of empathy well in the book
it's it's hard to argue that any of them
do in fact possess empathy
i was thinking besides um
rachel
but yes at least in the book they're
they're all very you know
what is it on schizoid is how they're
described yeah a psychiatric category
that we don't really use that much today
but what was very common when dick was
writing this in the 70s and the 80s to
talk about people being schizoid meaning
that they had a
flattened affect they didn't um how
would you say value things the way that
the rest of us do
you know
looked at things kind of very cold and
logical without you know a strong
empathetic response in any way yeah
so um
one of the things to keep going on with
this that comes up that'll lead us into
um talking about uh the empathy thing
itself is there's a test
that has been developed to figure it out
who's an android and who's a human being
and it's called the voigt camp test and
if you've ever seen the movie there's
like you know that there's that bladder
thing kind of sucking and you're
focusing on the person's eye it's it's
not quite so creepy in the book
and and
the one of the issues with the movie is
that it doesn't really
explicitly say what is going on it's
kind of right it would help if you've
read the book to know what the heck is
going on here with the voigt conf test
and uh but yeah it's the main thing here
is uh it's administered and it's asking
a number of questions or trying to
um elicit a uh empathetic emotional
response
um and it's looking for specifically um
autonomic responses that's why one of
the reasons that they're looking like
really closely at the eye to see like
you know you're on the automatic uh
how much your pupil dilates that's right
yeah yeah and then there was one other
thing as well uh was it skin
stuff or i don't remember exactly how it
works but there's two inputs and
androids fail when being asked these
questions although the the book begins
with and again the movie doesn't convey
this that well
um the book begins with worries about
whether the test is accurate or not so
deckard uh is going over to the rosen
corporation where he meets rachel rosen
who's you know played by sean young in
the movie
and
he's he's supposed to like check out
some of these new androids with the test
and the guy in charge says hey do it on
her she's a human being i want to make
sure that we don't get a
false positive
and then um
while she does test positive
for being an android and then
elgin i think his name is says oh well
see your test doesn't work because she's
a human being she was just raised out
there in outer space and that's why you
know she doesn't have the normal
emotional reaction so you're gonna you
know you're likely to be killing some
some human beings who don't have the
right reactions and this is a real worry
right you know who who counts who
doesn't
and then he um deckard gives her one
more question and
it's clear that that she really is an
android and then you know um she plays
an important role in the thing and he he
gives a couple more voigt camp tests to
other people including the opera singer
uh libba luft
um he also gives it to himself
and
he gives it uh
in conjunction with another
uh
bounty hunter right there
yeah right and so they're they're both
looking at okay
um
because at one point in time it is found
out that uh rick deckard's superior is
actually an android as well as his
entire like uh police district
phil resh uh rick deckert um
is being tricked
remember uh
phil resh is the one who's at the fake
police station
oh i've i've missed it it's easy it's
easy to conflate them i think yeah yeah
so but the main issue is
there
it's been found out that there's a whole
police station that was totally
how do we know that we're not ones like
especially after we've already talked
about
uh rachel rosen who on
believes that she is a human even though
that she's not
although later we find out she doesn't
right um that she's like i mean it's
unclear maybe she's being given like new
resets and new memories each time
but she sleeps with the bounty hunters
gets them to feel empathy towards her
and then they can't do their jobs
anymore
except for phil resh who she said was a
kooky guy you know although it's very
interesting if you're looking at phil
rush because um like rick deckard
um feels uh
his
connection to his electric sheep is a
rather
muted yeah he's he's not so like into it
like he does it because it is expected
um for someone to have an animal and do
it whereas phil rush he has a squirrel
and he adores his squirrel he gushes
about his squirrel he like the the
empathy comes easy for him for this
squirrel but
on in response to
uh
the androids
uh he has zero qualms about killing them
whereas rick deckard has
he begins to have qualms yeah yeah yeah
and and then and
likes killing him that's part of what's
different yeah so it's almost the
opposite of empathy right
right and and so
um it's been talked about like how
mercerism especially when they're
talking about to kill the killers yeah
is
a
kind of a perversion of empathy in this
i'm saying okay i'm going to weaponize
empathy and use it as something to
create an in-group in the out group and
i'm going to say oh we can empathize
with the humans
but we can't
emphasize with the the androids they're
the killers but also um it refers to
early on anyone can be determined to
killers not just the androids right and
it's up to those followers of mercer to
basically accuse and then dispatch the
killers
yeah
it's interesting too because mercer
again not in the movie at all but mercer
is going to show up in the book and talk
to
uh deckard
and deckard is really you know he's very
upset and he's like um
do i have to kill these androids it's
you know i'm having to go against my
own feelings and identity and mercers
like it almost sounds like something
coming from the bava god gita right
where um if you're a warrior well you
got to do a warrior's job don't don't
worry about it just do the job and
mercer himself is is saying this to
deckard um so we've talked we've hinted
a lot about
empathy we've talked a lot about
androids
dick actually has this great talk called
the android and the human that we wanted
to hit on well what distinguishes
androids and humans so he tells us that
our world and i think i mean this is
even more the case now
our man-made world of machines
artificial constructs computers
electronic systems interlinking
homeostatic components this is becoming
more and more to possess what
psychologists fear the primitive sees in
his environment animation in a very real
sense he says our environment is
becoming alive or at least quasi-alive
and in ways specifically fundamentally
here's the key word analogous to
ourselves machines are becoming more
human so to speak
so how do we how do we know what's
actually human and then he says i have
in some of my stories and novels written
about androids or robots or simulacra
the name doesn't matter what what is
meant as artificial constructs
masquerading as humans and then this is
very interesting he says to me that's
that theme seems obsolete
the constructs don't mimic humans
they are in many deep ways
already human
actually human already they're not
trying to fool us they merely follow
lines we follow in order that they too
may overcome such common problems as the
breakdown of vital parts loss of power
source attack by foes such as storms
short circuits and i'm sure any one of
us here can testify a short circuit
especially in our power supply can ruin
our entire day and make us utterly
unable to get to our daily job or once
at the office useless as far as doing
the work set on our
desk so he's saying
that
we're at least at that time that he's
writing um and talking
we're reaching the point where it's not
about just imitation
they're becoming like us they're not
just pretending to be us there's there's
lines that are being
crossed in a way right
right and so this
goes back to
um
when
uh deckard and uh remind me the other
bounty hunter
oh phil rash yeah phil resh are are
talking and they're giving each other
the white contest to make sure that
they're not yeah androids are themselves
is that you know at this point in time
um they have this discussion about um
is it okay to extend empathy to
the androids and they say like no no we
have to have this distinction there has
to be this line we are the thing that
holds that line between us yeah um that
is their job and
the question is
why
why do they have to be this line why
does their half as as these things
progress closer and closer to us yeah
why can't we extend that empathy to
these new things you know and there's a
couple points in the book where the
androids actually
they talk kind of bitterly about like
you humans
you
view us as like not even worth what a
cockroach is i mean they don't use
exactly that word i forget exactly what
they say but
um
there's this sense that maybe this
conflict doesn't have to
to be there
you know right now he he goes on in the
thing and he says in the field of
abnormal psychology the schizoid
personality structure is well defined
there's a continual paucity or lack of
feeling the person thinks rather than
feels his way through life and then he
says there's a certain parallel between
what i call the android personality and
the schizoid both have a mechanical
reflex quality
and then he says another quality of the
android mind is the inability to make
exceptions perhaps this is the essence
of it the failure to drop a response
when it fails to accomplish results but
rather to repeat it over and over again
lower life forms are skillful and
offering the same response continually
as are flashlights and then he says let
me now express another element that
strikes me as an essential key revealing
the authentically human
it's not only an intrinsic property the
organism but the situation in which it
finds itself
that which happens to it that which it
is confronted by pierced by and must
deal with certain agonizing situations
create on the spot a human
where a moment before there was only as
the bible says clay possibly the
difference between what i call the
android mentality and the human
is that the latter passed through
something the former did not or at least
it passed through it and responded
differently changed altered what it did
and hence what it was it became
now so this raises a lot of really
interesting questions
i i think about this book and what
happens in it because so if we've got
these three ways of identifying
um the android it's got a mechanical
reflex quality it has an inability to
make exceptions and it kind of just
sticks to its programming rather than
becoming
something new something something bigger
well that seems to apply to a hell of a
lot of humans doesn't it so that's
that's kind of scary to think about it
on the other hand
are there any android characters who
escape their programming
you know are we talking in this book or
in other so in this video i think the
answer is no
but i think in other dick stories the
answer is yes
or even the
um if we go to the film adaptations
you know especially like
on within blade runner
definitely i see that a bit with on the
rachel character yeah yeah um and and
also the question of is
um deckard actually a replicant himself
that becomes
much less known
yeah more mired and like is he or not um
and then even in the continuing what
about roy beatty at the end
oh yes
he saves deckard's life
giving him his life back gives that
wonderful speech that apparently rutger
howard made up
well i think the the main thing that he
made up was just that final line the um
all lost like tears in the rain about
okay the rest of that was was was part
was part of this yeah was it like
battleships on the uh um
i felt of orion exactly yeah
um
and it's it's a beautiful little thing
and a very
um
it's it's very much like showing this
this growth of these characters like you
know they're they're trying to
live their lives and their
and at the at least at the very end here
yeah yeah he he says like
he's basically having empathy and saying
i'm gonna let you live in this regard
and it results in his own death yeah and
that is empathy in the way that dick
means it so we should jump into talking
about empathy we've used this word a lot
yeah
the first thing we got to say is there
is no one single
take on what empathy is there's no
consensus whether in the present or
historically
so it's kind of a slippery word you know
it means a lot of different things
sometimes people will
confuse it with or distinguish it
against a whole bunch of other
moral vocabulary words like mercy
or pity or compassion
sympathy emotional contagion emotional
intelligence
and so there's there's no one single way
of parsing all of these
together and if you ask different people
like well how many different kinds of
empathy are there you're going to get
different answers some people say
there's two some people will say there's
four
some people will distinguish even even
more
psychology today has this nice little
thing empathy is the ability to
recognize understand and share the
thoughts and feelings of another person
animal or
fictional character we can empathize
with
rick deckard or with rachel rosen
and i think that's kind of right but i
don't know that that's exactly what dick
thinks i mean sharing the thoughts
it's more about like being able to
respond to the
feelings you know
i like the idea
of
appropriation of one's
of another's desires as well as and so
like bringing these things into yourself
yeah yeah
and
um knowing like okay they're probably
not gonna like if one does this to them
if they're in that situation yeah i'm
gonna kind of feel
poorly and they'd rather not do that so
maybe i want to you know
one you know have that same feeling or
to try to alleviate whatever is
happening therein i think appropriation
is a great term and
this is like way this is a big rabbit
hole that we're not going to go too far
but we've talked about it before well
this is a way that we translate the uh
greek term eukaiosis that plays a really
important role in stoicism in stoic
philosophy and it involves like a
affection for yourself and
and grasp perceptually of of yourself
which then you extend to others
sort of like you would to family members
that you you care about but i also think
appreciation
is another term here like if i have
empathy towards you
i appreciate what it is that you
think feel how you view a situation
so
you know decker talks about like
predator and prey
and says well a predator can't really
have too much empathy because then it
would realize its prey wants to stay
alive
you know
um but he has i mean he he's got
something like that developing for these
androids
yeah and that's uh continue on with the
spider analogy they're making these
things about like
um predators as these uh solo
um
individuals that go around and so
they're they're not social creatures
yeah unless that's the reason why they
they get to this is like lack of empathy
thing but any creature in which lives in
social groups has to develop empathy and
so yeah it's one of our favorite topics
that we think about is as us humans we
are social primates that is one of the
main ways that we interact with the
world and how we develop as a species
and that is has a very strong impact on
how we see the world now spiders are an
interesting topic for for three reasons
one is
there are spiders who are not only you
could say not empathetic towards their
normal prey there are spiders who prey
on other spiders who actually go over to
their webs and like pull on the web to
simulate another kind of insect and when
that spider comes down then the the
hunting spider jumps on it and and eats
it right so that's that's one extreme
but we also do seem to have social
spiders right we have those spiders that
make those vast webs together
and so i don't know i'm kind of
conflicted about this spider example and
then we have a spider of course in the
story who is the subject of the
android's
torturing it
effectively right yeah yeah and it it's
one of the reasons why jr is a door
uh i'd say uh
betrays them because he was kind of
working with them to a certain extent
but he
watches as priss on one of the androids
slowly pulls off its legs and says like
kenny walk with only four and he is
absolutely beside himself in watching
her commit this act of cruelty to such a
small creature yeah
and then roy actually he's like it's not
moving so we'll light a match and you
know put it right the spider and then
the spider takes off
so there's additional cruelty on top of
that
yeah this is definitely
one of the big differences between the
book and the movie is that the in the
uh the book uh over and over and over
again the androids are really shown to
like
strongly lack this empathy and they lack
empathy towards each other too i mean
that's that's something that comes up is
an android will sell out another android
and and they say that the characters
themselves like roy beatty um when
isidore is choosing to protect them
um the three androids that are staying
with him are like wow you know we
wouldn't do this for each other
this guy look at this guy you know and
uh of course then they they as dan just
said they ruin it by um
torturing the poor little spider
so coming back to empathy you know
before we get into
you know looking at how it figured into
the book itself um
some people want to make a distinction
between you know cognitive and emotional
empathy whereas like cognitive you you
can like place yourself in the other
person's position you can like think
about what life would be like for them
and then you can respond i guess you can
reason it through properly and that
emotional empathy is where you actually
feel caring or
where you it i mean the book has a
really great thing
you
you um
feel joy at others joy
you feel suffering at others suffering
and
um i mean this is like aristotle talking
about friendship where he he actually
makes that in his nickel mccain ethics
one of the hallmarks of friendship that
if you're friends with somebody really
friends with them
you feel good about them feeling good
you feel bad about them feeling bad you
know
um
and then it's interesting because uh
in addition to these cognitive and
emotional there's there's other
theorists like daniel goldman the
emotional intelligence guy who wants to
add a third dimension being
compassionate and again we see this
blurring between compassion and empathy
right are they different are they the
same and so being compassionate would be
like when you have both cognitive and
emotional empathy and then you do stuff
you actually so it might we might
instead of calling it compassionate we
might call it like action-oriented you
do things that are
empathetic or you do empathy towards the
other person
you know
like you see somebody crying at their
desk in the workplace right and you go
over
and um you say oh hey what's what's
going on you know and then they start
telling about something
now of course this could get you in
trouble in some workplaces but you put
your hand on their shoulder you know you
say it's gonna be okay that might be
what compassion and empathy looks like
although interestingly and one of the
themes that is explored here in the book
is the difference between
performative empathy and actual like
actually filling that so we see this
with decker where he's kind of more
performative with his uh care of the
sheep
um
versus others like um
with the squirrel yeah
as we talked about earlier do you think
do you think uh i mean
it just occurred to me
so deckard has a wife in the book that
he doesn't have in the blade runner um
he
feels
some empathy or he exhibits some empathy
towards her but do you think that in the
very beginning it's more performative
than
than actual and she shows empathy
towards him towards the end of the book
but yeah
i mean early on he's like i should have
divorced her when i had the chance
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
deckard's a little bit of a sad
individual overall
um i i don't know i maybe he had mc at
one point in time for her oh
but maybe i don't know i'm i'm
uncertain yeah i mean but that's another
thing it's not as if we have like
unlimited capacities for empathizing
right
that is
a whole extra discussion i think yeah
i do want to catch uh another topic
quickly if you don't mind on about uh
memory and and how
um one of the big things that they're
talking about of like what makes person
not only is it this
uh this empathy response but also the
memories that they possess
um and this is explored um even more in
like blade runner 2049
right right and
one of the big things that we see is
their um you know effective response um
to two things and so they have like this
really poor at least in the original
book as well as in blade runner they
have this really poor effective response
to things that should be um
empathetically stunning whereas
yeah
as you continue on especially if you
even if you see with um
uh rachel um she has a full set of
memories all going all the way back to
childhood but they are fake memories and
so they are implanted memories and as
well as in blade runner 2049 on the the
newer models of these uh nexus
robots um from the tyrell corporation
are actually having these and that what
it seems to be is that it allows the um
androids to
uh
have a
more
able to
um control their uh emotional responses
because they have this like grounding
memory given to them
but
this also really strongly reminds me of
on be a skinner and the idea of the
skinner box
interesting so you got to explain that a
bit for our audience yeah um
and so
[Music]
well he was a big maybe a psychologist
yeah so
i i think i've actually just uh
conflated two things what is the box in
which you um have you can go into it and
you can experience everything well
that's the experience machine
exactly i'm sorry no
yeah i mean i can see connections to
both though um i mean
skinner's basic idea was operant
conditioning that you would um i mean he
kind of thought like people are
basically meat robots you know
um so you got that on the one side and
then the experience machine which we
talked about in in previous episodes we
were talking about thought experiments
yes it's a machine you go inside and you
pre-program it and it gives you like
super
lifelike
experiences to the point where you don't
know that you're not really experiencing
it and you can set it for like you know
two years and then it uh something dings
and you leave it or
whatever right or whatever you want so
the androids are basically it's as if
they've been
brought up in an experience machine
right which is exactly so like a
stimulus response thing because it's
supposed to produce certain emotional
effects
right because you're basically by
creating this whole series of memories
you are creating a expected output from
inputs which is definitely the skinner
box
and the experience machine um also very
much explored in other books especially
we can remember it for your wholesale
which turns into
um total recall right
yeah
um is uh this
exactly the whole idea that we we've now
made these new
androids that actually have these full
memories is that what makes someone
human um in that because at least within
blade runner 2049 these uh new androids
are much closer to humans than
at least in the original one and and
they're closer to how they're portrayed
as rachel in blade runner i mean if we
have to depend on memories being
really really true in order for us to be
human we're all screwed because our
memories of things are very much like
you know we call them confabulations
right
in a lot of cases
um even when people have traumatic
memories which is preserving something
that you know they might choose to
forget otherwise there's still some
distortion going on
um it's interesting too that in the book
human beings are said you can't really
implant fake memories in them like you
can in an android because it it um
screws them up
um whereas it works out well for for
androids
yeah
um any last thoughts before we go
through are
you know
in the movie i i kind of like that thing
that you pointed out that rachel
she's not rachel rosen she'd be rachel
tyrell then right um
she
does seem to develop um which shouldn't
be
happening possible yeah yeah
so
in a way the the movie is a little bit
more optimistic about um
android's capacity to develop i mean she
she clearly has empathy
for deck deckard in the movie um
although she doesn't in the book she she
reveals that i mean she sleeps with him
yeah but it's a ruse exactly yeah
yeah
i think there's a
um we only talked about on the kipple a
little bit but there's definitely this
connection between both the um empathy
and as a building up versus
the killers which are entropy which are
breaking down things
um and that's another nice um
juxtaposition that i think uh i would
love to talk about at another time yeah
and mercer is right at the heart of it
because in the discussion of kipple and
the tomb world and breakdown and all
that
um
mercer is is viewed as the exception to
this world that's just in in collapse so
yeah that's a great
uh
theme i would say yeah yeah
so
apropos we leave you today with the
words of philip k dick
our flight must be not only to the stars
but into the nature of our own
beings because it is not merely where we
go
but what we are as we make our
pilgrimage there
our natures will be going there
too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you